attorney general republican nomination
this one is fairly close with segal
chateau facing tisha black but again
this is about eight percent between the
two
contenders here 49 percent to 41
meantime our current attorney general
aaron ford easily winning rio
re-nomination as well brian denise let's
now look at the congressional races dina
titus easily winning 84 percent of the
vote in a dominating lead let's look at
the congressional district one
republican who will face her mark
ammaday will hang on 30 percent to david
bragg with 16 percent
hang on to his seat for cd2 moving on to
cd3 let's keep it moving there there's
the numbers mark m day 56 percent over
danny tarkanian uh 32 percent and then
april becker 68
a huge lead in cd3 also we have word
coming in that susie lee
easily winning there's the numbers with
susie lee with a dominant 90 percent in
congressional district 3. also sam
peters at this point is 48 percent a
closer race over annie black this is
congressional district four and they
will face stephen horsford the winner
will with